และ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมไวต่อสัญญาณรบกวนมาก
ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งรบกวนที่ทำให้เกิดข้อผิดพลาด
ในการคำนวณ แต่งานวิจัยใหม่แสดงให้เห็นว่า
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมแบบ noisy ของ IBM สามารถจับคู่กับวิธีคลาสสิกที่แม่นยำได้
และพิสูจน์ได้ในทุกช่วงที่ทำงานได้ดีกว่าวิธีการประมาณแบบคลาสสิกที่ซับซ้อน
ทั้งในช่วงที่ตรวจสอบได้
และช่วงที่เกินการตรวจสอบ
สำหรับการทดลองจำลองที่ท้าทาย
พวกเขาทำได้ยังไง? พวกเขาใช้เทคนิคพิเศษ
สำหรับจัดการกับสัญญาณรบกวน
ในระบบควอนตัม เรียกว่า error mitigation
ด้วยเทคนิค error mitigation
ที่ใช้ในการทดลองนี้ เราเรียกใช้การคำนวณของเรา
แล้วค่อยๆ เพิ่มระดับสัญญาณรบกวนขึ้น
จากนั้นเราก็ extrapolate กลับไปหาจุดที่ไม่มีสัญญาณรบกวน
งานนี้พาเราเข้าใกล้การใช้ quantum computing อย่างเป็นประโยชน์มากขึ้นอีกก้าว
เรา